[Musique]
m
la ryder cup la plus grande compétition
de golf au monde c'est parti à saint
quentin en yvelines et sur tv 78 nous
allons vous faire vivre cette semaine
l'événement 80000 spectateurs attendus
ici à saint quentin en yvelines au golf
national la ryder cup fédère à des
millions de spectateurs dans le monde
entier les meilleurs joueurs américains
tenant du titre vont affronter les
meilleurs européens
pour la première fois sur le sol
français chacune des équipes ne manque
pas d'arguments pour s'imposer les
capitaines et jim furyk est au mas bjorn
ont fait leur sélection nous passerons
tout à l'heure en revue les forces en
présence et puis qui dit événement
majeur dit forcément quelques
précautions à prendre sur les routes
rappelle et conseils pour la circulation
à la fin de cette édition
même si le golf vous êtes étranger vous
avez forcément entendu parler de la
ryder cup
troisième événement le plus médiatisé au
monde quatre mille cinq cents
journalistes sont en train à d'arriver
ici et 495 millions de foyers vont
pouvoir suivre les affrontements à de
ses meilleurs joueurs européens et
américains si vous voulez encore plus de
chiffres pour bien comprendre l'enjeu de
cet événement regardez ce reportage
la ryder cup est aujourd'hui la plus
grande compétition de golf au monde
créée en 1927 par samuel ryder un homme
d'affaires anglais au rendez-vous et
aujourd'hui regardés par un milliard de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde et
rassemble près de 250 mille supporters à
chaque édition c'est un roland garros
multiplié par 20 c c'est une chance
c'est des jeux olympiques c'est quelque
chose que le public français va
probablement avoir la chance de voir une
fois dans sa vie
sur le plan sportif la ryder cup oppose
les 24 meilleurs joueurs au monde 12
européen et douze américains sur trois
jours de compétition au rendez vous est
organisé tous les deux ans en alternance
aux états unis et en europe sur les plus
beaux golfs internationaux cette année
et c'est le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a été à
sélectionner quant aux règles elles sont
simples et indémodable 16 matchs en duo
sont programmées le vendredi et le
samedi le dimanche tous les joueurs
s'affrontent en face à face chaque duel
rapporte un point au gagnant un demi
point distribué à chaque joueur pour un
match nul la première équipe à atteindre
le score de 14 points et demi est
déclaré vainqueur de la ryder cup en cas
d'égalité c'est l'équipe tenant du titre
qui soulève la coupe
au niveau du calendrier un match entre
célébrités européennes et américaines
est programmée le mardi le mercredi ce
sera au junior de s'affronter dans un
match amical le jeudi une série
d'ouvertures est organisée avec la
présentation des équipes et un concert
géant à compétition débutera
officiellement le vendredi 28 septembre
pour se terminer le 30 septembre avec
une remise des trophées à 18 heures
philippe lattaud bonjour directeur
adjoint de ce golf national vous
attendez cet événement depuis des années
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
soulagement avec quelques jours quelques
heures presque du coup d'envoi ou est-ce
que le stress est tombé son maximum bon
en fait bonjour est en fait une
concrétisation effectivement ça fait
sept ans qu'on attend ce moment là et
donc c'est plus une concrétisation est
un rêve
oui un rêve qui se réalise et oui il ya
pas trop de stress là les derniers mois
manquer ce qui se joue en ce moment là
les joueurs vont découvrir le parcours
ce sera jeudi vraiment les derniers
moments de répétition et puis ensuite le
fait compétition effectivement il ya moi
il ya toujours un petit peu de stress
parce qu'on a envie de donner
voilà tout ce qu'on a on a envie de
satisfaire le montrer au monde du golf
conte et voilà deux capables de de
produire un bel événement après derrière
je pense que ça va être beaucoup de joie
beaucoup d'émotion et c'est vrai que là
sur les jours qui vont arriver savez
aujourd'hui une journée assez calme
demain les entraînements officiels vont
commencer donc mardi mercredi jeudi et
je pense que le stress raoui
effectivement présents certainement
entre entre vendredi et dimanche au i
qui était aussi la météo peut-être en ce
moment là il fait un peu plus frais ya
quand même du soleil c'est ce qui
devrait y avoir toute la semaine est ce
que ce sont des bonnes conditions
mais les conditions sont parfaites à
cette semaine parce que c'est vrai que
si fait un petit peu frais le matin
mais après les conditions devraient
avoir un 18 à 20 degrés donc avec du
soleil dont cela va être formidable très
bien parlé un petit peu compétition les
états unis qui sont tenant du titre est
ce qu'ils vont conserver ce titre selon
vous une forte équipe
ils ont une très forte équipe août ce
qui a gagné son 80e tournoi hier donc je
pense qu'ils vont arriver vraiment
gonflé à bloc et c'est vrai que ça va
être ça va être je pense de très beaux
matchs et des beaux matchs qui vont
aller loin ce qui est génial également
pour le spectacle et des matchs qui
seront certainement très très très serré
oui tout à fait faire la différence
je pense moi je pense pas grand chose je
pense qu'après derrière c'est vrai que
c'est ça reste du match play donc après
derrière je pense que ça va être
je pensais joueurs qui sont capables de
supporter cette pression là de supporter
le public et et je pense qu'après
derrière ça va se jouer sur des petits
détails des potes qui tombe ce qui tombe
pas quoi il se dit aussi que ces deux
équipes qui sont alignés sont les
meilleurs jamais alignée est ce que
c'est le cas ouais bah oui si vous
regardez le classement mondial et si
vous regardez les joueurs qui
participent à la compétition sur les pas
dire de bêtises mais je crois que sur
les les 14 premiers mondiaux 15 premiers
mondiaux il ya quatre joueurs qui qui
joue là la compétition donc oui c'est
c'est énorme
honnêtement c'est énorme et même si a
pas de français dans le lot un petit
regret tout de même ici au golf de pas
accueillir de français sur les greens
on espérait tous cette année
effectivement qui est un joueur français
lévy a acquis qu'ils puissent participer
au tournoi c'est vrai qu'il ya un peu de
déception à ce niveau là après derrière
on sait c'est le jeu c'est le sport de
haut niveau
sport de haut niveau fait que voilà
cette année c'était pas la bonne année
on espère qu'il sera et qui sera en tout
cas qui est un joueur français dans deux
ans aux etats unis avant tout ça juste
pour terminer cet entretien le match des
célébrités aussi qui va se jouer dès
demain ici il ya quelques noms déjà
ouais on a quelques-uns pour ceux qui
aiment les sports de glisse sur la kelly
slater qui sera là pour ceux qui aiment
le cinéma samuel lee jackson qui sera là
guy forget yannick noah ou et donc des
noms et puis ça va être génial de les
voir ici évoluer sur le site non
honnêtement c'est génial ça si ça va
être je pense un bon lancement pour
cette belle semaine
merci beaucoup on vous retrouvera tout
au long de la semaine merci philippe
lattaud merci
je vous le disais la ryder cup est à
suivre au plus près sur tv soixante dix
huit jusqu'à jeudi à partir de 18h45
vendredi ce sera dès 18h30 ce week end
sur notre page facebook live et puis à
lundi 1er octobre à 7,8 sport est
spéciale à ryder cup nous ferons le
bilan à partir de 18h30 avec michael et
demi d'euros les américains sont donc
les tenant du titre en 2016 ils ont
soulevé le trophée vont-ils le conserver
le point sur les forces en présence deux
équipes
un seul objectif sauver cette 42e ryder
cup au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
les visiteurs américains détenteurs du
titre espère bien le conserver en
alignant des top 10 du circuit mondial
comme justin thomas sont encore dustin
johnson pour conquérir une 27e ryder cup
le capitaine américain jim furyk a
également décidé de sélectionner la
super star du golf mondial tiger woods
et phil mickelson qui honorera sa 12e
sélection l'équipe américaine on la
compare à l'équipe de basket des jeux
olympiques à la dream team et c'est vrai
que c'est la dream team vous avez le
numéro un mondial qui est américain
numéro deux mondial est américain et le
numéro 3 mondial est américain donc
c'est vrai que ça va être un match
fantastique
l'équipe européenne a également sorti
les muscles sur cette compétition
retrouvera des jeunes à fort potentiel
qui joueront leur première ryder cup
comme l'espagnol john rabe ou le danois
thorbjorn olesen et des joueurs
d'expérience comme le golfeur italien
francesco molinari l'anglais justin rose
et le nord irlandais rory mcilroy qui a
déjà participé à quatre éditions des
choix de thomasz berne dans les quatre
wild cards
rééquilibre un petit peu la jeunesse des
joueurs qui se sont qualifiés
automatiquement vous avez des joueurs
comme stenson des joueurs comme poulter
des joueurs comme garcia qui sont des
joueurs d'expérience et qui viendront et
poulet les rocky qui eux se sont
qualifiés d'office dans cette équipe on
retrouvera également dans cette équipe
suédois alex noren vainqueur du dernier
open de france
c'est le joueur européen en forme
il s'est donc imposé il ya quelques
semaines sur ce même parcours du golf
national
ça va être un homme à suivre il en plus
particulièrement attachant le joueur
suédois
je lui prédis de nombreuses victoires en
double et en simple à la ryder cup qui
remportera ce duel de géants entre les
états unis et l'europe réponse ce
dimanche 30 septembre aux alentours de
17 heures et à l'attraction la tête
d'affiche côté américain se sera
notamment tiger woods le joueur de 42
ans a révolutionné son sport et malgré
ses déboires personnels
il reste extrêmement populaire un tigre
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le capitaine
de la sélection américaine jim furyk a
décidé de sélectionner tiger woods
l'homme aux 14 tournois du grand chelem
pour la ryder cup 2018 fin septembre une
invitation attendu après le bel été du
golfeur sur les meilleurs tournois
mondiaux est finie filet dans l'est dans
les six premiers à l'open britannique il
est deuxième à lui à ce budget il est
toujours devant quoi ce cirque en
randonnée tiger et revient aux affaires
en plus on sent un joueur en tout cas il
paraît beaucoup plus détendue beaucoup
plus ouvert on sent un joueur qui est
qui et qui moi qui ait moins de tournées
vers lui un peu plus vers les autres et
je pense que ça a dû penchés également
dans la balance dans le dans le choix du
du capitaine américain tiger woods le
golf national ce n'est pas une première
le golfeur avait participé aux
championnats du monde amateurs en 1994
sur le parcours de l'albatros avec ip
américaine avait gagné à le score par
équipes mais il n'avait pas finir les
premiers méfaits
voilà un beau tournoi mais n'avait pas
fini premiers apprenez en individuel
au-delà de l'aspect sportif la venue du
golfeur de 42 ans absent d'une ryder cup
depuis 2012 devrait doper les audiences
sur le circuit américain le nombre de
téléspectateurs et multiplier par deux
camps le tigre et sur le green qu'on le
voit sur les tournois qui joue sur
lesquels il se remet en
en forme le dernier à speed g kiwi fini
deuxième où ils ont battu tous les
records d'audience
tiger woods internationale c'est un rêve
je pense et on pouvait pas rêver mieux
si les statistiques médiatiques sont du
côté de tiger woods sur le terrain la
ryder cup ne sourit pas aux golfeurs en
sept participations le sportif ne l'a
remporté qu'une seule fois en 1999
vous voulez venir assister à la rider
vous avez déjà vos places vous savez que
ce n'est possible que grâce aux navettes
qui ont été mises en place pour
l'occasion et pour les autres que vous
suiviez ou non la compétition il va
falloir prendre vos précautions pour
circuler vous le voyez la venue du
centre passera de deux à une voie les
deux rues fermées sont celles qui
encadre cette fameuse avenue à noter
cependant que les places de
stationnement de ces trois rues seront
aussi fermées puisqu'elles sont destinés
à accueillir les navettes les autres
fermetures concernent les accès proche
du golf national sont concernés l'avenue
du golf le chemin de vie larroy la route
de l'aéroport et une partie des avenues
de l'europe et léon blum petit conseil
essayez d'éviter saint quentin en
yvelines entre 6h30 et 8h30 à partir de
17h
[Musique]
pour ce kit avec l image du jour ce sont
les deux capitaines réuni pour la
première conférence de presse du tournoi
il a été question de leur préparation
des prochains jours de la découverte du
circuit pour certains et puis de
l'effervescence de l'atmosphère
particulière
et puis bien évidemment les deux
capitaines ont été interrogés sur la
performance de tiger woods à ce week end
écoutez ça fait depuis le début d'année
que tiger woods jeu très bien il
commence à frapper aux portes des grands
majeur il a eu plusieurs opportunités de
l'emporter cette année donc forcément ça
crée une effervescence dans notre équipe
mais le fait que tiger woods soit en
pleine forme bien ça va ajouter encore à
cette excitation qui règne autour de la
ryder cup veut voir tiger woods au
sommet ce second veut puisqu'il fait
tellement de choses pour notre sport et
je regardais le jour hier soir je
trouvais qu'il était brillant et celle
du meilleur pour lui pour notre sport
lui-même et donc quand on arrive dans ce
tournoi qui rassemble les 24 meilleurs
joueurs au monde
c'est un tournoi qui a son histoire ses
particularités c'est une bataille sans
pareil à tous contre tous et c'est tout
simplement ce qu'on attend in tiger
woods qui gagne c'est quelque chose qui
est bon pour notre sport et donc nous en
bénéficions tous parce que en fin de
compte
mais quoi que fassent les 24 joueurs
quand vous avez quelqu'un comme lui qui
transcende de sport et qui le rend
populaire auprès du plus grand nombre
forcément c'est bon pour le sport
prochain rendez vous avec la ryder cup
sur tv 78 ce sera mardi 18h45 il sera
notamment question du match des
célébrités avec beaucoup d'animations
ici vous allez voir
[Musique]
m